there's a particularly poignant way one
can be a social disaster through over
friendliness a pattern of behavior
driven by the very best of motives which
ends up feeling as irritating as
outright rudeness we meet the
over-friendly at the office laughing at
the jokes of the senior management
behind the desk at the hotel
wishing sir or madam a highly enjoyable
stay and across the table on a first
date lavishly endorsing there would be
partners every opinion about recent
books and films the over-friendly
are guilty of three large errors firstly
they believe they must agree on
everything if the other says the world
is going to the dogs they immediately
not in consent if a second later there's
a prediction of a utopian technological
future they'll agree just as much when
we say something clever they're thrilled
when we say something equally daft they
like it no less their ritual approval
may seem attentive in truth it's a
version of not listening at all secondly
their praise is ill targeted plenty of
nice things are being said but they're
not the ones that we happen to value
they claim to love our umbrella our
credit card is from their favorite bank
our chairs are deeply beautiful we
apparently have a nice way of holding
our fork but none of this counts for us
if it isn't connected up with our own
sense of meaning and achievement
everyone loves being praised but to be
praised inaccurately is its own kind of
insult thirdly their friendliness is
remorselessly upbeat they point out how
well we look how impressive our job
sounds how perfect our family life seems
they want to make us feel good but they
dangerously raise the cost of revealing
any of the lonelier darker more
melancholic aspects of our characters by
contrast the less ardently friendly and
therefore properly pleasing person will
keep three things closely in mind
firstly the disagreement isn't
necessarily all always terrible that it
may be exhilarating to be contradicted
when we don't feel that our dignity is
at stake
and that we're learning something
valuable at the hands of a combative
interlocutor secondly that people only
want to be complimented on things that
they are actively proud of the value of
the currency of praise depends entirely
on it not being spent too freely and so
the truly pleasing person knows they
must pass over many things in discreet
silence so that when they eventually do
bestow a blessing their words can have a
proper resonance thirdly that we are
cheered up not so much by people who say
cheery things as by people who appear to
understand us which usually means
sympathize with our sorrows and show a
willingness to travel with us to the
anxious hesitant or confused parts of
our psyches what enables the pleasing
person to please is their capacity to
hold on in social encounters even with
rather intimidating and alien seeming
people to an intimate knowledge of what
satisfies them they instinctively use
their own experience as a base for
thinking about the needs of others
by contrast the over friendly person
allows themselves to forget their own
likes and dislikes under the pressure of
an excessive humility which suggests to
them that anyone impressive could not
possibly share in the principles that
drive their own psychology at the core
of the pleasing person's charm is a
metaphysical insight that other people
cannot deep down ever be very other and
therefore there in core ways what one
knows about oneself will be the master
key to understanding and getting along
with strangers not in every case but
enough of the time to make the
difference over friendliness
isn't just a feature of one-to-one
encounters it's an entrenched flaw
within modern consumer society more
generally this explains why the airline
exuberantly wishes us a perfect day upon
landing in a new city or why the waiter
hopes we'll have a truly wonderful time
around the first course and why the
attendant in a clothes shop pulls such a
large smile along with their suggestion
that we try on a new pair of trousers
here to the cause of an asphyxiating
friendliness is a sudden modesty and
loss of confidence
around using oneself as a guide to the
temperament and needs of a stranger
companies become over impressed by the
apparent other 'no son there by overlook
how many aspects of their own selves are
being trampled upon in a service context
they sidestepped the knowledge that just
after landing back home after a trip
abroad we may feel horrified at the
thought of our responsibilities in the
family or that moods of introversion and
sadness can accompany us even inside a
clothes boutique they behave as if they
were cheerful Martians encountering
broken complex humans for the very first
time the fault of the excessively
over-friendly person can in the end be
traced back to a touching modesty they
are guilty of nothing more than a loss
of confidence in the validity of their
own experiences as a guide to the
pleasure of others the failure of the
over friendly types teaches us that in
order to succeed at pleasing anyone we
must first accept the risk that we might
well displease them through a candid
expression of our being successful charm
relies on an initial secure sense that
we could survive social failure
rehearsing how it would in the end be
okay to make a hash of seducing someone
is perhaps the best way to seduce them
properly and confidently we must
reconcile ourselves to the risk of not
making friends to stand any chance of
actually making any
you